hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to baldies unreal
basics and education and learning we're
gonna go on to chapter 2 as much as I
didn't want to you guys wanted me to so
thank you for that but I'm gonna go into
the basement and I don't know what the
basement holds for me but I can only
assume that it's going to be bad I
actually don't even know if it's gonna
be all that fundamentally different but
that being sure [ __ ] my hanging why am i
hanging ohh
why am i upside Doon oh there I go ow
how I only broke my neck when that
happened but thank you no boy so um Oh
control I don't know what I'm
controlling or why I'm controlling it
but I can only okay find a way out of
the school's basement there's a way out
in the fire escape there's a fire escape
to the basement what does that mean oh
hey okay cool that's nice
oh it's gonna be a different type of
game this time oh it is fundamentally
different can I go this way yes I can
fire exit well so easy huh all right I
believe you I believe you I don't
believe you I don't believe I didn't
believe you
oh the basement must have flooded from
all the rain try to find a way out of
there before Baldy catches you there are
five generators you must activate before
you can leave what why is this a thing
Oh God danger high voltage keep out okay
can I get a soda pop can I get a soda
pop you're run from there's soda oh oh
oh I hear a Spanky Wumpus oh okay then
coming from that way alright well Paul D
if you whose just if it's just you and
me down here I I don't think it's gonna
be too much of a problem I ain't got a
bad feeling about this I only feel good
how do I just that easy huh just a
little click in a car clunk and it's
done okay alright Baldy
alright listen Baldy listen buddy here's
some nice water effects down here but
something tells me I'm not gonna be
happy about
when I get more generators going on and
why are their lockers down here why
these lockers look more that's the light
from the thing that's fine
why do those lockers look more like
cages our students kept down here in
cages now the problem is it's
fundamentally different I don't know
where every oh I don't know where
everything is but I think this is
loopback oh [ __ ]
hi Baldy hey I know why that's a loop
now so I can go around
hey Baldy listen body body body Baldy
body you bald buddy hey you are looking
so handsome did I ever tell you that I
love you ruler you aren't gonna spank me
with that are you okay well you have fun
take care love you lots
I'm just making sure that he actually
goes hey you are I do not like that hey
can you stop being so sudden about
everything can I stop being caught on
everything before oh I see yeah I see an
arm why is he a Baldy okay yeah I don't
think I can sprint I think I only have
one speed now yep so I'm still keeping
away from him over at one and maybe it
was a good thing that I only went over
there first because I got two of them
and that's nice but if there's more of
them I don't think I'm gonna be raw able
to run away oh hey look at these well
that's nice
gonna get that do you expect me to come
back around and go past you cuz I don't
think that's gonna go well for me oh oh
the ass is getting sloppy can you not do
that because I don't even know where the
generators are let alone where I'm
supposed to go oh boy I see this is for
that might be a loopback but that's all
I know
oh he's getting real sloppy good chunk I
can only hope there's something good
over here
oh she's real sloppy okay no it's just
what that's just a loopback but that
doesn't make any sense
but then there was nothing holy are you
there oh hi hi how you go okay you know
what you don't need to do that but I
need to make sure he's gonna come this
way so he actually loops around and
doesn't just cut back the other way oh
[ __ ] no my ass is grass oh it's so
slapped oh I'm gonna get so [ __ ] I'm
slapped
oh I'm slapped what does it mean when
you're slapped and doomed at the same
time I'm slow pooned if there's no other
way to go besides just here so that's it
oh [ __ ] unless there's another way to go
out here but I don't think there was and
if I go in there it's just gonna be a
death trap it's gonna be isolated and
I'm not gonna be able to go anywhere and
there's nowhere to go and it's [ __ ]
Hey hi okay Baldy you don't need to do
this let me tell you one thing if
there's one thing that you don't need to
do it's definitely this so don't do that
ah [ __ ] um oh oh hey secret way good hi
Baldy hi
okay listen you we can talk about this
week and uh oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] oh I'm dead
I'm dead I'm done though I'm done zones
oh oh I'm done so he's gonna get so fast
don't don't
bang body-wise now
[Music]
okay so that didn't go well so if I'm
supposed to understand this correctly
how the hell am I supposed to be able to
get away from him because that's what
I'm having trouble understanding okay
what I think I got it yeah oh goody
forgive what I think I gotta do is I
gotta get this one first cuz I can't go
over here I mean I could but I don't
think it'd be good for me if I did I'm
definitely not faster when I sprint so
this is the only option I have I go from
here and then that's it so what it must
be I think what it is I think I'm gonna
be fine if I just go about this the
right way and not the wrong stupid way
which is a lot of ways that I actually
want to go about things but not today I
don't want to go about it that way so if
I just lead him over here I gotta wait
until I get a good bit away from him
then he's gonna get happier and sloppier
what I need to do is I need to lure him
down this way and then go around
ah mr. sloppy ass oh hey that was your
name huh you summoned by that or you
just pissed off by me using that you
didn't think anybody would remember that
nickname from school mr. sloppy ass
alright we'll come on down this way I
think he took the bait I think he took
the bait he didn't take the bait he did
not take the bait negative on the bait
taking a [ __ ]
ah that's not that's not ideal that is
not ideal that is the opposite of ideal
okay well I'm boned I think I can still
get away from them a little bit but what
I got to do is I got to make sure that I
go over to the end of it first and then
hit this one on the right last and then
that's what I need to do cuz I need to
hit that one cuz I can just bounce off
of that one real quick like so I'm
assuming that this is gotta be the last
one I got to do I'm really strategic
about this which means I'm using a lot
of brain power and I don't usually have
that so I'm just trying my best here
everyone just bear with me cuz he's
about to get sloppy alright here we go
where is he where's there he is okay boo
oh here we go
come on come on mom okay this has got to
work right he's got to work or else I'm
just doomed I might be doomed I might be
doomed but I figured it's gonna work I
think is he following this way please
take the sloppy bait yes oh he took I
shouldn't have looked
I shouldn't look back that's probably
gonna cost me that's gonna cost me
that's gonna cost me big Lee huh oh
that's gonna cost me big Lee okay we're
going we're screwed Alan as fast we can
skadoodle now if I can just NAB that one
run the rest of the way and then I'm
good to go
right oh god I'm not gonna be able to
cut back fast enough oh god [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay go no no Baldy pay
[Music]
I shouldn't have looked back I shouldn't
look back I shouldn't look back that one
time I shouldn't look back I should have
just trusted that he was gonna be sloppy
on the way over there that's my bad it
was my dad that was my bad okay I can do
that again I could do that again one
okay
I'm back into it I think I think the
strategy is still right my brain is
telling you that it's right my brain has
never failed it before except all those
times that I was an idiot come on Bubba
come on Bubba come on Bubba come on big
boy who's your big boy who's your big
boy other areas come on big Baldy boy I
don't even know how you got down in this
basement that just raises up a whole
nother bag of worms but I'm just gonna
I'm gonna assume they're nothing to
surreptitious about this and just go on
as if everything's okay come on over you
definitely get it over this time right I
wanna see I wanna see that slappy area
is too sudden I don't like that as much
so I just got to get around grab the
last one and I'm good to go so long as I
don't screw it up like I did before I
can do this
real easy peasy like I just got a trust
I got a trust that he's not going to go
this shortcut way even though that's
what I would do because I'm a dick and I
love to cheat but if he goes that way
he's an [ __ ] I'm not an [ __ ] for
using the very clear way that I'm
supposed to go come on come on come on
okay I'm gonna trust I'm a trust and
trust in I'm trusting
I'm putting my trust in the system I
trust the system
I trust the system this is some orcs he
wouldn't cheat he's no cheater he's no
slouch does he allow a cheater
he's no cheater he's no slouch yes okay
I think I got it
I think I'm here to go I think I'm gonna
go I think I'm gonna go okay I think I'm
gonna go if I just going here I snagged
this I get out I go on I am good
we made it dick diddly hoho let's go
okay
these fans please not that fast is that
that fast fast fast
he's not that bad [ __ ] and flowers as
they gathered
come on hey Oh what are we doing what
are we doing
No what that's it right there's more why
is there more oh no don't do that
there I got it what are we gonna do here
okay all right what am i doing what am i
doing I don't know what I'm doing what
am i doing
we're going how do I get up there I
can't jump how do i how do I jump how do
i how do I jump
whoa there's a pleasurable object you
can press Q to jump on it oh oh okay all
right I like that
Chris cute it jump on it okay all right
what if I just push it directly over
here okay
No
what oh oh oh
okay okay okay all right ah [ __ ] I'm a
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I
oh [ __ ] how do i hello oh [ __ ] how do I
push it back how do i oh [ __ ] me no no
you can't do this to me no please I
can't how do I um how do I get it out
how do I get it out of the corner okay
um I want to push this oh please I'm
begging you please oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no no no not like this not
like this not like this
no no like this no please please I'm
begging you I don't want to restart no
please no there's nowhere to go god damn
you no no no god [ __ ] damn it okay
yeah I'll go back to the chapter select
let's just forget that I just did all
that [ __ ] let's just forget that let's
go back because you make a push opal box
where there doesn't need to be a push
above ox why would you make a push'
bilac s' there that could get trapped in
a corner why couldn't you just put the
Box where it needed to be and then oh my
god
if there's one thing that I can always
trust in these types of games is that it
just pisses me off and then I have to
live with the consequences of that anger
now I knew our Baldy fields now I know
how Baldy feels I bet I bet I bet I bet
that's it
like I bet that's it I bet that's the
end you just gotta push it and then you
go up and then that's it and then no
more ha ha that's the end oh there you
are come on come on big man
come on you big lipped man come on you
Rosie Lipton luscious man you Squidward
nosed [ __ ] come here it's fine
I'm fat I'm fine I'm happy I'm a happy
man I'm a happy man with happy dreams
and I'm gonna go do this again cuz I
know how to do it and it's easy so not
that bad it's just a few minutes out of
my life that I'll never get back a few
minutes that Baldy has robbed me of my
life my precious life the only thing I
have in life is time and it is takin it
from me that's okay hey Baldy come here
come here you will rapscallion you there
you are
alright come ba ba ba ba ba ba ba now
don't be a dick about this better not
actually be a dick about this go the
right way are you going the right way
yeah I got this it's good it's all good
it's all good
hey it's all good it's all good baby I
got this I'm gonna push the blocks
correctly because that's a skill that I
don't have in gaming ha ha ha and I'm
gonna get we're into the vent and that
fine fine
you're gonna you're gonna okay and we're
here
great okay we're here again great
wonderful okay so we're here yes
here is where we are here is where we
are hey wow I'm gonna push you right
there get up on that Oh like a dreamboat
I'm so glad that was that done dunzo
one's oh I win so if that's the frickin
end of this chapter I'm gonna throw my
computer out of window
[Music]
bah alright okay I'm on that backup
computer now I threw that one out of the
window so that's fine all right cool
well that was not worth it but there we
go that was that was Chapter two I'm
also gonna play chapter three because I
hate myself and I want to suffer but I
imagine that if I'm ready for all the
[ __ ] that they're gonna throw at me
it won't be so bad right so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to support the channel click the
join button become a member of the
channel today you get a bunch of special
perks for it and you get to see some
super cool behind-the-scenes videos so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]